in this trap we're going to see the pawn
take on E5 which is pretty common and
then black pushing forward with the for
is defended by the queen here can always
gobble up this material later and you
may see white play E3 now they could
think that yeah I'll go ahead and take
your Bishop right here this is a mistake
by black because then you're going to
play your queen down here the king's
going to recapture doesn't matter if you
take with your Pawn right here
fortunately for white black has other
things up his sleeves and if he does
take with his Bishop here on
B4 then the Pawn's going to take here on
F2 this is check King comes to E2 and
now the critical move and that is the
pawn takes here on G1 can turn into any
piece it wants to it's going to turn
into a knight check the king is going to
move away from the queen and the queen
is going to fall or if the king comes
back here to E1 Queen comes to H4 check
King to D2 not in the best spot